[Musique]
et
non
on lui fait remarquer systématiquement
dans son entourage que de toute manière
il les clubs la cinquième roue du
carrosse il ne sera jamais appelé à
régner donc ce n'est pas quelqu'un qui
qui prend la vie à bras le corps et il
sera toujours un peu comme ça même en
vieillissant puisque il a mérité ce très
beau surnom le henry le beau ténébreux
[Musique]
les valois dynastie régnante pendant la
majeure partie de la renaissance ont
joué un rôle important dans la formation
de la nation et de la monarchie
française
les premiers d'entre eux survécu aux
attaques de l'angleterre durant la
guerre de cent ans puis au moyen-âge ils
terminèrent l'unification des provinces
préparant ainsi le terrain pour le plus
célèbre des valois françois 1er on admis
aujourd'hui encore son apport en
architecture et dans les arts et lettres
ainsi que son importation en france de
la renaissance italienne
mais c'est son fils et successeur henri
2 qui va permettre à ce nouveau courant
de se développer et de connaître son
apogée
[Musique]
quand henry 2 et reed la couronne de son
père françois 1er la renaissance en est
comment diriger à son apothéose c'est ce
qu'on appelle la première renaissance et
la deuxième renaissance ce sera celle
que l'on va connaître durant le règne
d'henri ii c'est à dire que hilali des
non seulement de faire travailler les
italiens mais de faire travailler des
architectes français eux mêmes
influencés forcément par l'italie mais
qui vont marquer les monuments de leurs
empreintes on songe à philibert delorme
à l'escaut et puis notamment le travail
du mobilier avec il existe ce qu'on
appelle un style henri ii et bien c'est
véritablement inspiré de ce qu'on a créé
les meubles concrets les grands
fauteuils les coffres et c'est tout ça a
été créé à l'époque du chayran reid son
règne fut court et l'on se souvient
surtout des deux femmes qui dominèrent
sa vie son épouse florentine catherine
de médicis et la maîtresse qui
l'accompagna toute sa vie diane de
poitiers
henri de valois était toutefois un hub
les vaillants chevaliers et fut le roi
bien aimé de la plus belle cours
d'europe
sa mort prématurée eu de graves
conséquences et marqua le début du
déclin des valois
n'ayant 15 119 henri de valois duc
d'orléans est le second fils de françois
1er et de claude de france incapable de
donner un héritier à louis xii
prédécesseur de françois 1er
anne de bretagne avait accordé la main
de sa vie claude à son cousin françois
d'angoulême héritier présumé la reine
claude était une femme douce et très
pieuse sa constitution fragile avait
beaucoup souffert de la naissance de
trois fils et quatre filles en l'espace
de neuf ans françois 1er établit d'abord
sa cour au château d'amboise dans la
vallée de la loire
mais la reine préféra se tenir à l'écart
et résider avec ses enfants au château
de blois berceau de son enfance
[Musique]
elle y était entourée de ses dames de
compagnie parmi lesquels deux jeunes
femmes anglaises marie et anne boleyn et
la belle diane de poitiers
[Musique]
henry 2 est un personnage assez méconnu
dans les premières années de sa vie
c'est un cadet et les cadets on ne s'en
occupe parents s'occupent
essentiellement de l'enfant destiné à
régner sur le royaume de france c'est à
dire son frère aîné françois henry 2
donc va par contre être élevée avec son
frère va bénéficier aussi d'une
éducation sauf que cette éducation de
par les événements politiques de son
père et notamment les histoires après
pavie et l'incarcération de ses deux
enfants en espagne et bien sera
complètement laissé tomber c'est à
partir de 11 ans finalement que
l'éducation de ce prince va reprendre et
de se peaufiner jusqu'à devenir
l'éducation d'un d'un presse mme de
l'époque henri duc dans les eaux est un
enfant joyeux et vigoureux il a 5 ans
quand sa mère meurt son père confie
alors les enfants royaux à diane de
poitiers première dame de la reine elle
connaît les petits depuis leur naissance
bien qu'il soit surtout connu pour avoir
fait traverser les alpes à la
renaissance italienne et à léonard de
vinci lui même françois 1er au début de
son règne porte toute son attention sur
les conquêtes militaires et l'extension
de son royaume
au xvème siècle après avoir chassé les
anglais de france ses prédécesseurs
s'étaient affrontés au duc de bourgogne
ceci pour se protéger avait conclu un
certain nombre de mariages d'alliances
avec les habsbourgs dynastique que l'on
connaît pour avoir régné sur l'espagne
l'autriche et le saint-empire romain
germanique
ces liens avaient fini par créer une
véritable hostilité entre les valois et
les habsbourgs ce climat d'antagonisme
s'intensifie avec françois 1er et
charles duc de bourgogne la vertu des
unions dynastique
le prince de habsburg nommé plus tard
charles quint va hériter des empires
espagnol et autrichiens et être élu
empereur du saint empire romain
germanique les territoires des habsbourg
jouxtant la france de toutes parts
françois 1er doit leur démontrer sa
force
les valois estimait avoir un droit
ancestral sur l'italie du nord
les deux rois qui avait précédé françois
1er s'étaient emparés de ce territoire
puis en avaient été chassés le jeune roi
se donne pour mission de reconquérir les
villes perdues par ses ancêtres va loin
en italie
son rêve obsessionnel de posséder milan
va créer une tension permanente entre la
france et les habsbourgs tension qui se
poursuivra durant le règne de son fils
[Musique]
la brillante victoire de françois 1er à
marignan en 15/100 15 ramène milan sous
la domination française
mais elle engendre aussi un nouveau
conflit avec charles quint à la fin d'un
hiver rigoureux
les français sont vaincus en 15 125 lors
de la bataille de pavie
le roi est alors fait prisonnier et
emmenés en espagne après une année
pénible de captivité il est relâché et
promet à charles de lui livrer en
échange ses deux fils le dauphin
françois ducs de bretagne et son cadet
henri duc d'orléans seront ainsi retenue
en otage plusieurs années en espagne
en attendant que soit exécutée les
conditions du traité de madrid
le traité de madrid stipulait que les
princes un premier pouvait donc être
libéré à la condition que est pas une
rançon et pour gage du paiement de cette
rançon
eh bien les espagnols avaient demandé
soit les meilleurs militaire qui
existaient encore dans le royaume de
france et qui n'avait pas été tuée à
pavie soit les enfants de france à dire
les héritiers le dauphin françois et son
frère cadet donc qui sont livrés en
otage qu'ils vont vivre pendant quelques
années dans des situations je veux dire
assez assez cruel assez austère sans
sans affection sans entourage et il ya
cette scène merveilleuse que au moment
où le petit henri franchi la frontière
sur les rives de la besace de la
bidassoa il avec lui sa gouvernante et
sa gouvernante l'embrasser tendrement
lui disant j'ai hâte de vous retrouver
cette gouvernante s'appelait diane de
poitiers en traversant le fleuve en
direction du sol français leroy croisa
au milieu du gué le bateau qui emportait
les deux enfants âgés de 7 et 8 ans vers
leur prison ému il leur dit de prendre
bien soin d'eux de manger comme il faut
et qu'il enverrait bientôt les chercher
certes françois désiré le retour de ses
fils sains et saufs mais il n'avait pas
l'intention de céder un pouce de son
territoire à son rival
il va passer trois ans à chercher le
moyen de contourner les conditions
inacceptables pour lui du traité les
princes sont d'abord bien traités mais
charles comprend que françois ne jouent
pas franc jeu et leurs conditions de
détention se détériore henry se remémore
la tendresse de vienne de poitiers et
rêve de sa douze beautés pendant les
quatre années qu'il passe sans recevoir
la moindre marque de tendresse dans la
forteresse espagnole le duc d'orléans et
transformé lorsqu'il revient de
captivité tandis que son frère le
dauphin parvient à laisser derrière lui
ce traumatisme
il se noie dans la rage et le
ressentiment il ne supporte pas d'avoir
été abandonné si longtemps en espagne
françois 1er qui aiment que ça court
soit gaie et vivante n'apprécie pas de
voir son fils dans cette humeur henri
apprend à ravaler ses émotions et sera
dès lors perçu comme un être rigide
sombre et mélancolique françois lainée
est appelé à régner jusqu'au jour où
hélas il a bu pense-t-on un peu d'eau
croupie aujourd'hui on appellerait ça
une diphtérie bref il meurt très
rapidement et henry 2 enfin henry qui ne
vais pas appelé à devenir dauphin
devient le futur roi de france
alors tout change à partir de ce moment
là françois 1er va veiller sur lui va
essayer de lui inculquer des notions
politiques puis les notions de culture
générale et il va demander précisément à
cette dame que l'on connaît comme sont
allés dire son institutrice
diane de poitiers 2 veillait sur
l'éducation du petit henry
le roi ne viendra jamais en aide à henry
mais il facilitera son retour à la cour
dans un premier temps il permet à ses
fils de reprendre des forces à anet
auprès de diane de poitiers et de son
mari louis de brézé le plus âgé des
courtisans et de leurs deux filles
la femme qui prie tendrement henry dans
ses bras à l'heure de son départ est
celle qui va le protéger à son retour
diane qui porte le nom de la déesse de
la lune et de la chasse est la seule
capable d'apaiser les tourments d'henry
et les soins qu'elle prodigue au prince
orphelins vont finalement s'épanouir en
un amour qui ne s'éteindra qu'avec la
mort c'est encore l'époque de la
chevalerie et de l'amour idéalisé le
petit henry âgé de 12 ans tous tes prix
de diane
lui jure publiquement lors de son
premier tournoi fidélité et protection
se présente comme son chevalier et
demande à porter ces couleurs le noir et
le blanc diane touché par la galanterie
de l'adolescent continue à veiller sur
lui et à combler les lacunes de son
éducation dû à son isolement en prison
françois 1er quant à lui n'abandonne pas
ses rêves d'italie en rire devient
bientôt un pion dans la stratégie
politique de son père
celui-ci négocié avec le pape clément 7
un mariage d'intérêt
henri de valois devra se marier avec
l'héritière orpheline des médicis
catherine n'est pas de sang royal
car les médicis ne sont que des
marchands qui ont été anobli son arrière
grand père était laurent le magnifique
puissant diplomate homme politique aimé
sène auprès de savants d'artistes et de
poète né à florence d'un père italien et
d'une mère française elle est devenue
orpheline quelques jours après sa
naissance elle a grandi sous la halle
des papes médicis au cours de la guerre
sanglante qui les a finalement chassé de
florence
elle échappe à la mort en se réfugiant
dans un couvent jusqu'à ce que son
cousin le pape
l'appel à rome
françois 1er a pour projet de reprendre
florence et d'installer le jeune couple
à la tête du duché de milan
l'idée pour françois 1er en tout cas
dans les années 15 130 parce qu'il n'a
plus d'argent pour faire monter une
armée
eh bien il va essayer de jouer avec la
diplomatie et comme charles quint va
mettre un holà à ces fermes par rapport
au projet du mariage de son fils de son
fils henry avec une de ses filles à
venir ou une de ses nièces et bien
françois 1er va chercher d'autres alliés
en italie parce qu' on n'a plus du tout
et va sur ses pattes
je ne veux plus te pose le plus la lazio
qui pourrait être le plus puissant pas
forcément militairement mills au plan
politique et clémence et allait à
l'époque à une nièce catherine qui a
exactement le même âge à 15 jours près
que l'on dit et qui vit dans un couvent
qui potentiellement héritière de
de florence mais aussi du public du fait
du rebond et que ce mariage là pour ans
pour françois 1er permettait donc du
coup d'implanter la france dans un
territoire où la france devait ne
pouvait avoir des droits dont sol du cdh
urbain et avec l'appui en puces
politique de du pape qui lui permettait
soit de revenir sur milan soit d'aller
vers naples le roi d'angleterre henry 8
accepte de conclure une alliance avec
françois 1er si celui ci arrive à
convaincre le pape d'annuler son mariage
avec catherine d'aragon
il est impatient d'épouser anne boleyn
malheureusement clément 7 meur un an
après le mariage d'henri et catherine
son successeur paul iii s'allie à
l'empereur l'alliance médicis valois
n'est plus d'aucune utilité pour la
france mais le roi françois 1er campe
sur ses positions
durant tout le reste de son règne il
sera tantôt amis tantôt ennemis de
charles quint avec l'italie toujours
entre eux henry et catherine en 14 ans
lorsqu'il se marie en 15/100 33
catherine tombe amoureuse de son bel
époux dès le premier regard
de son côté le jeune homme ressent
fortement la pression qui pèse sur ses
épaules
sa nouvelle femme est charmante mais
tout petit et pas très joli et le choeur
d'henry est déjà pris par vente de
catherine par sa mère
diane de poitiers devient sa demoiselle
d'honneur alors âgée de 30 ans elle est
à présent veuve elle est grande mince et
sa passion pour la chasse le doter d'un
corps ferme et élancée henry idolâtre
cette femme au grand front et aux longs
cheveux d'un blond vénitien son
affection pour sa plus sur confidente mi
femme mi ds va se transformer en un
amour charnel
[Musique]
alors henri épouse catherine de médicis
à laquelle il finira par faire des
enfants au bout d'une dizaine d'années
alors qu'il vivait tendrement avec diane
de poitiers avec son institutrice qui un
jour à une déclaration d'henri telus ali
je vous aime
alors c'est assez assez étonnant parce
que diane de poitiers était la plus
belle femme du royaume du temps avait
elle a 15 ans épouse un vieux bar bond
de 55 ans le sénéchal de grand sénéchal
de brézé de sénéchal de normandie et
après la mort de monsieur de brézé
qu'elle n'a jamais trompé d'ailleurs
c'est une femme tout à fait stricte en
amour très fidèle après sa mort elle va
succomber aux avances d'henri 2 qui
pourrait être son fils donc après avoir
épousé son père elle va vivre avec son
fils
henry et diane tombe amoureux peu de
temps après le mariage du jeune homme
n'ayant connu jusqu'à présent que son
mari qui avait 40 ans de plus qu'elle
diane est sensible attention de ce jeune
et beau chevalier à 15 ans henry est
grand joli garçon est très athlétique en
raison de leur différence d'âge et de
leur extrême discrétion
la plupart des courtisans ne voient dans
leur relation que l'affection partagé
entre une mère et son fils catherine de
médicis elle sait parfaitement que les
mariages sont des mariages politiques
sont pas forcément des mariages d'amour
elle nous charmait pratiquement et que
l'idée d'une favorite ou d'une concubine
existe déjà la cour de florence ne les
plains corps de robes déclin aussi en
italie c'était monnaie courante est
arrivé en france et elle a vu son époux
avec une maîtresse sap a dû choquer
grand monde en tout cas et surtout pâle
catherine pensez bien que le fait qu'il
ne soit pas de sang royal pousserait la
cour à la négliger mais elle n'était pas
préparé à devoir faire face à une rivale
auprès de son mari
diane est sûre d'elle intelligente et
très influente à la cour dépossédé de
son rôle d épouse catherine se consacre
à la seule fonction qui lui reste donnée
au prince un héritier mais elle reste
stérile durant les dix premières années
de son mariage
des rumeurs de divorce commençant à
circuler
elle use de tout son charme pour gagner
l'admiration et la protection du roi
françois 1er en utilisant leur goût
commun pour tout ce qui est italien elle
se tourne vers l'occultisme pour trouver
des remèdes à cette infertilité ce qui
commencera à lui bâtir une réputation de
magicienne
voire de sorcières aujourd'hui il semble
avéré que le problème était lié à henry
mais catherine surmontent les obstacles
et donne naissance à un fils en 15 144
de ce mariage naîtront dix enfants dont
7 survivront
si elle remplit largement son rôle de
génitrice catherine échoue dans celui
d'épousé mentent elles tentent bien de
gagner l'affection d'henry mais il n'a
d'yeux que pour sa maîtresse en même
temps catherine sait ce qu'elle doit à
diane car sans les exhortations de celle
ci henry ne serait jamais venu dans son
lit elle se résigne donc à cette étrange
ménage à trois tout en adoptant la
devise a hissé et attendait
quand le dauphin françois ducs de
bretagne meurt subitement henry devient
le nouveau dauphin leurs terres françois
1er aurait préféré voir son troisième
fils charles en situation de lui
succéder
plutôt que ce jeune homme mossad ans
qu'il ne se reconnaît pas charles connu
pour ses frasques son extravagance et sa
frivolité à l'entière approbation de son
père mais il meurt lui aussi
prématurément le roi le coeur brisé
devra encore faire face à la perte d'une
fille avant de rendre l'âme
en 15 147 henry n'a jamais pardonné à
son père de l'avoir envoyé en captivité
en espagne de l'avoir privé de son
enfance mais il remplit néanmoins son
devoir filial
ils commandent aux grands peintres cloué
l'effigié du souverain organise ses
funérailles en l'église notre dame et
fait édifier un splendide monument à la
mémoire de ses parents l'enfant soit
premier murray henry hérite la couronne
il va la garder pendant pendant une
douzaine d'années je crois et bombay il
faut il faut gouverner et avec ti vct at
il souhaité gouverner bien notamment
avec son grand ami qui était celui que
son papa adoré d'ailleurs que françois
1er adoré un quelqu'un qui avait été à
marignan qui était connétable de france
c'est anne de montmorency et anne de
montmorency henry 2 le considérait
vraiment comme son père en quelque sorte
un c'est avec lui qu'il voulait
gouverner la personnalité
particulièrement sombre d'henri à
l'opposé du charme flamboyant de son
père évolué à la mort de ce dernier
c'est comme si le poids qui pesait sur
ses épaules s'envolait il a 28 ans et
maintenant il détient le pouvoir après
les 90 jours de deuil traditionnels il
est sacré en la cathédrale de reims et
devient henry 2
puis le nouveau roi fait son entrée dans
les principales villes de france
françois 1er ne l'a nullement préparés à
diriger le pays henry va donc chercher
aide et conseil auprès de ses deux
mentors anne de montmorency et diane de
poitiers il le restera dévoué jusqu'à sa
mort
c'est ainsi que l'on disait qu'il y
avait deux étoiles dans le ciel de son
règne
le soleil et la lune anne de montmorency
veille sur la couronne n'entend que
connétable et maréchal de france
diane règne sur le coeur et l'esprit du
roi en tant que maîtresse et conseillère
élevé de façon très stricte
diane impulse un changement radical dans
la morale de la cour
l'accent est mis sur la piété l'économie
et l'évolution vers des réformes
sociales et législatives les
ambassadeurs un visite à la con remarque
la haute tenue des courtisans et des
brillants esprits qui inspire la
politique de la france
[Musique]
catherine manquant d'instinct maternel
c'est diane qui s'occupe également des
enfants royaux
il passe de sa demeure d'un net au
château de fontainebleau durant l'hiver
de blois amboise au tour durant le
printemps de la muette ou de saint
germain pendant l'été et de compiègne au
cours de l'automne
henri offre à diane le château de
chenonceau sans doute le plus enchanteur
de tous
il est cerné de forêts profondes où le
gibier pullulent sous l'oeil
bienveillant de diane henry poursuit
l'oeuvre de mécénat de son père et créé
un climat intellectuel et artistique qui
rivalise avec celui des grandes tours
d'italie
françois 1er a apporté à la france la
renaissance mais c'est un orri que
revient de lui donner toute sa dimension
diane de poitiers était une femme
remarquable elle était sportif elle
pratiquer la marche à pied la natation
la chasse et c'était une femme qui était
très propre
elle prenait son bain d'eau froide
tous les jours toute l'année et l'eau
qu'elle envoyait ses domestiques
chercher aux pluies l'eau qui n'avait
pas vu le jour
toujours pour ne pas abîmer sa peau
[Musique]
toujours aussi belle à 46 ans diane est
accusé de recourir la magie et aux
sortilèges pour conserver l'éclat de sa
jeunesse elle devient la principale
source d'inspiration des beauté
classique de l'école de fontainebleau et
comme fontainebleau fut le chef-d'oeuvre
de françois 1er
annette devient celui d'enrayer de diane
c'est un temple en leur honneur leur
amour est sincère il célèbre la
rencontre parfaite du corps et de
l'esprit
[Musique]
il ya deux types de château xvième
siècle château de cours comme blois
comme vincennes comme le louvre et les
châteaux privés comme fontainebleau
comme annette par exemple pour pour ce
règne avec henri ii c'est un château qui
n'est pas forcément une demeure une
maison qui abrite un amour ou une amitié
puisque l'affection de henry pour diane
de poitiers si elle devra tout le tout
la vie de henry la relation amoureuse va
s'arrêter dans les années 20 où début d
année 450
c'est de cette maison donc est un centre
de gouvernement puisque là il y tient un
conseil mais c'est aussi un rebond du
rendez vous de chasse une demeure de
plaisance mais qui qui est à cheval en
fin de compte entre l'objet politique
est l objet l'objet privés etc
c'est un château qui a été là encore
financés par la diane de poitiers avec
l'argent que henry de quelques fois à
donner ou les bénéfices qu'elle avait pu
obtenir par ce règne c'était un objet
excessivement moderne comme si
aujourd'hui elle aurait vécu dans une
maison dessinée par starck ou quelque
chose comme ça faut s'imaginer de la
chose et c'était un objet qui est aussi
en concurrence par rapport à un tous les
objets construit bâti de ce type comme
moi aussi on a fait à chantilly ou à
l'écran c'est à dire une sorte de
surenchère comme ça sur la modernité et
sur l'originalité de lui
on est alors à l'apogée de la
renaissance française
jamais dans l'histoire de france une
cour ne fut si magnifique et si galante
mais un autre mouvement se fait jour au
même moment la réforme la politique
d'henri 2 face à la menace protestante
est la seule grande ombre de ce règne
glorieux
à cette époque les monarques pensait que
l'intégrité de leurs royaumes dépend des
de l'unité religieuse du peuple
françois 1er avait tenté de concilier
son désir d'humanisme et sa promesse de
punir les résines les conseiller d'henri
sont tous deux connus pour leur
intolérance
si la persécution des protestants
avaient déjà commencé sous françois 1er
elle ne fait que s'amplifier
sous le règne d'henri ii on est en
pleine guerre de religion la période
nouri 2 c'est le début des guerres de
religion exactement et en vidéo n'est
pas très partisan de la cause du but not
to protestante
en cela il est extrêmement influencé par
diane de poitiers qui a été élevé dans
le catholicisme pur et dur et qui lui
dit henry a lui dit il ne faut pas que
les mots est une influence considérable
on va d'ailleurs à cause des lots ou
grâce à elle dirait disaient les
catholiques de cette époque-là signe
lady descoings qui interdisait le culte
protestant sur le royaume de france et
est les premiers les premiers massacre
des protestants vont avoir lieu à cette
époque là puisque on se moquait le diane
quand elle elle elle se promenait on
disait les protestants nous sommes ici
ton du pendu et brûlé avec le feu
qu'elle a aucune c'est l'expression
utilisée dans paris il n'oublie pas non
plus les mauvais traitements que charles
quint lui a infligé en espagne et lui
garde une profonde haine
quand l'empereur tente d'annexer aux
pays bas espagnols cambrai et les villes
principales de la lorraine province
protégé par la france henri de riposte
et s'empare de metz toul et verdun entre
les habsbourgs et les valois la chance
continue d'hésiter comme lors de la
lutte pour l'italie une courte trêve est
concluant 15 156 après l'abdication de
charles quint en faveur de son fils
philippe ii d'espagne mais en quinze 157
marie tudor reine d'angleterre et
nouvelle épouse de file et déclare la
guerre à la france
les forces espagnoles envahissent le
pays depuis les pays-bas et remporté une
écrasante victoire à saint quentin
l'armée venus secourir la forteresse
assiégée et décimé la tragédie de
saint-quentin oblige la reine à venir à
l'aide de son mari pendant cette
campagne catherine alors régente
convainc le parlement de lever des fonds
pour continuer la guerre ce succès à
croix l'admiration du peuple pour
s'arrête
l'année suivante les forces françaises
bombarde khaled dernière possession de
l'angleterre sur leur territoire cette
campagne est caractérisée par la
hardiesse de ses dirigeants la ville
sera prise forts de ce succès les
français se dirigent vers dunkerque et y
mettent le feu
le maréchal de termes s'empare de la
ville qui sera cédée aux espagnols en 15
100 59 par le traité de cateau cambrésis
toute l'europe pratiquement est en cause
un l'angleterre la hollande l'espagne et
tous ces pays là vont devoir signer
enfin signé les accords de cateau
cambrésis mais en deux temps d'ailleurs
puisque avec l'espagne ça va signer je
crois que c'est le 3 mars
et puis avec l'angleterre le 5 mars
alors en quoi consistent ces accords et
bien se sont sensiblement des affaires
religieuses parce que henry 2 cède
toutes les ses prétentions sur l'italie
en demandant à l'espagne de l'aider et
éventuellement contre les dinos et avec
l'angleterre
eh bien il joue le jeu contraire il dit
à elisabeth la reine d'angleterre
eh bien écoutez en effet vous avez
consacré le culte anglicans chez vous je
ferme les yeux mais vous me rendais
calais il a récupéré calmer cette paix
de 459 est essentiel parce que elle va
permettre à la fois de mettre un point
final à plus de 40 ans de guerre n'est
pas rien à recréer des liens entre l'
empire conduit non plus par charles
quint parce qu'il abdique aimé par son
fils philippe 2 et en partie en tout cas
et par l'angleterre qui maintenant est
sous la tutelle de elisabeth 1ère c'est
aussi une période donc où on affirme où
la france va affirmer définitivement en
tout cas pour l'instant mais c'était
dans les textes ça ne sera plus après
son abandon de l'italie et mais cette
paix là encore à est à double tranchant
comme toutes les autres faits c'est à
dire qu'en gros c# si henri ii a accepté
cette paix qui paraît pour beaucoup
aujourd'hui une peine malheureuse parce
que quand on
imagine qu'il a rendu toutes ses
conquêtes 220 c'est à dire la corse une
partie du luxembourg une partie des
flandres et la savoie et plus tous ses
droits qu'ils avaient sur j'aime sur
milan sur naples si on monte un peu plus
haut dans le dans l'histoire on
s'aperçoit que déjà françois 1er a
abandonné tous ses droits en italie et
puis il ya aussi cette et cette logique
qui fait que dans les traités de paix tu
es bien on rend ce qu'on a occupé mais
seront sur lesquels on sur ses terres
sur lesquelles on n'a pas de droit
justement cette paix va apporter une
paix définitive en tout cas que ces
personnes là nous qui gagnent tant
d'argent en faisant la guerre en italie
ou ailleurs et bien nous aurons pu ses
bénéfices eh bien on râle avantage au
moins d'avoir repris calais et donc
empêcher des anglais de débarquer sur la
france aussi facilement et puis aussi de
garder ces trois évêchés toul verdun et
metz qui tu es et territoires qui
étaient des enclaves à la main à
l'intérieur du royaume de france et qui
ont en tout cas proche et les proches du
duché de lorraine et qui permettait aux
allemands ou en tout cas où nous
opposant thériault devenir plus
rapidement en france et est ravagé la
picardie la champagne voire même menacé
paris stratégiquement s'était finalement
très très fin mais c'était pas
spectaculaire par rapport à une idée de
conquête d'autre part cette paix quand
je lui ai dit avait un repère et
hallyday 2,2 henry 2 était de deux
projetés maintenant toute son énergie
contre l'angleterre pour faire sa
conquête pendant que la guerre est au
centre des préoccupations
le calvinisme peut se propager sans
obstacle la banqueroute liées au coût de
ces campagnes et la peur du
protestantisme pouces henry 2 à accepter
un traité avec l'espagne et à lui
abandonné ce pourquoi les monarques
français se sont battus depuis quatorze
194 philippe ii a le contrôle des postes
clés italiens les français gardent
calais ce qui marque la fin des
incursions anglaise en france
le traité de cateau cambrésis est signée
le 2 avril 15 159 et met fin à la guerre
entre les habsbourgs et les valois bien
que la défaite soit humiliante la paix
permet à henri d'envisager l'avenir avec
un optimisme nouveau l'amour et le
respect qu'il porte à son épouse en
sortent grandis sa reine lui a donné une
grande famille et lui a apporté en tant
que régente le soutien dont ils avaient
besoin pendant qu'il guerroyaient enfin
lé récent mariage d'alliance qui lui ont
été imposées semble vouée au succès le
jeune fils du roi et de la reine
françois 2 a épousé la fougueuse marie
reine decosse l'année précédente lors
d'une fastueuse cérémonie avec la mort
récente de marie tudor épouse de
philippe d'espagne la belle fille
d'henri 2 peut prétendre au trône
d'angleterre
alors on sait qu henry 2 qu'est parti
semble du pape catholique dans l'âme
profonde et mangue et surtout grâce à sa
maîtresse diane de poitiers qu'il l'est
plus encore et bien est très proche des
10 qui eux sont sont également des
catholiques pur et dur et en faisant
épouse et la petite marie et marie
stuart à son fils françois de son aîné
eh bien il introduit les 10 à la cour
française puisque marie est la fille
d'une guise précisément
le couple royal organise des fêtes
somptueuses pour le mariage de leur
fille aînée elizabeth de valois avec le
monarque le plus important d'europe
le roi philippe ii d'espagne
l'usagé voulait que les traités soient
souvent scellée par un mariage entre les
belligérants pour assurer la paix et
l'équilibré entre les deux pays
il semble que ces mariages royaux
annonce une ère de prospérité pour la
france elisabeth de valois est une des
filles de henri ii et va épouser donc
après comme tous les pères se finissent
souvent par des mariages ou en tout cas
on l'espère c'est pas toujours le cas
mais bon en tout cas là pour de cette
fois ci ce sera le cas elle est donc
elle va épouser philippe ii d'espagne
est donc lié par le mariage
en plus des traités de paix et d toutes
les contracte motif est donc lié
spirituellement deux nations qui se sont
fait la guerre pendant 40 ans c'est à
dire la france au cours des célébrations
un tournoi est organisé au palais des
tournelles durant trois jours le roi
henry contre l'avis de ses ministres et
de son épouse participent aux joutes au
cours des deux premières journées le roi
montre ses talents et rivalisent de
prouesses
mais durant la troisième il rate son
assaut contre le compte de montgomerie
capitaine de sa garde écossaise et
insiste pour faire un nouvel essai
montgomery et le roi font deux fois le
tour de la lys se rencontrent et sera à
la troisième rencontre leur lance volts
en éclats mais montgomery ne relève pas
la sienne à temps lapointe perce la
visière du home du roi entre dans son
oeil
et atteint son cerveau la reine pousse
un hurlement les palefreniers se
précipite et saisissant riz alors qu'il
est en train de tomber le roi est
conduit dans sa chambre au palais des
tournelles doté d'une forte constitution
physique il va agonisé pendant 11 jours
soigné par deux des médecins les plus
éminents de l'époque au moment où son
état semble s'améliorer et où l'on pense
qu'il va se rétablir une infection se
déclare et il succombe le 10 juillet 15
159 le roi demande plusieurs fois à voir
sa maîtresse mais la reine refusera
qu'elle entre dans sa chambre depuis 25
ans catherine de médicis rêve du jour où
diane va mourir pour gagner enfin
l'amour du roi et diriger le royaume à
son côté ce coup du destin met fin à son
rêve
et
plongez dans l'une des plus belles
histoires d'amour de tous les temps le
roi henri ii n'a eu que peu de temps à
consacrer à sa postérité
il laisse derrière lui quatre fils et
une reine qui à sa mort va assumer un
rôle public
après être resté 26 ans dans l'ombre
elle est alors mère d'un enfant roi dans
un royaume en faillite est divisé sous
le regard de deux autres maisons
désireuses de prendre le contrôle du
trône ce qu'on appelle le règne de
catherine de médicis va couvrir les 30
dernières années du gouvernement des
valois c'est à dire plus longtemps que
celui du roi
fille d'un célèbre mécène de florence
catherine de médicis et passionné
d'architecturé et a le désir de laisser
derrière elle deux grandes réalisations
mais avant elle doit effacer un lourd
héritage l'amour transcendant denrées de
etienne de poitiers catherine oblige
cette dernière a échangé chenonceau
contre chaumont et à restituer les
bijoux de la couronne
diane se retire à anet où elle meurt à
l'âge de 66 ans
[Musique]
on procède ensuite à la transformation
des monogrammes qui ornaient les
châteaux royaux
henry avait gravé le sien et celui de
diane un peu partout les haches et des
rouages et un croissant de lune sont
facilement regrt avait en h essais pour
catherine
catherine ne portera que du noir jusqu'à
sa mort et immortalise son chagrin en
choisissant comme symbole une lance des
miroirs brisés des noeuds d'amours
déchirés et des lettres c et h
symbole de la douleur de catherine sont
sculptés dans la pierre des édifices
les projets de construction de catherine
de médicis comprennent le palais des
tuileries l'autel de la reine à paris
des extensions au château de chenonceau
et la chapelle des valois à saint denis
le palais des tournelles ou et moore
henry 2 est complètement abandonné
catherine décide de construire à cet
emplacement sa nouvelle résidence
parisienne et de tracer des jardins à
l'endroit où se trouvait avant des
fabriques de tuiles ce sera le jardin
des tuileries ses jardins tout proche du
louvre où elle a élu domicile s'étire le
long de la seine et offre à l'époque une
vue imprenable sur la campagne vers le
sud et vers l'ouest
le palais des tuileries et le premier
palais que catherine fait sortir
entièrement de terre il va devenir le
plus grand projet de construction du
dernier quart du 16e siècle
[Musique]
l'architecte à l'origine de l'oeuvre
philibert delorme a enseigné à la france
le style classique rationnelle et
régulier mais pour catherine il y ajoute
des ornementations et de riche matériau
les colonnes pilastres et lucarne des
tuileries sont des chefs-d'oeuvre de la
sculpture de cette époque
seul le rez de chaussée de la petite
galerie sera achevé de son vivant ce qui
permettra à henri iv d'ajouter un second
étage qui reliera les deux palais du
louvre et des tuiles
à la mort de delorme en 15/100 70 c'est
jean bullant qui lui succède comme
architecte en chef auprès de catherine
comme elle est lasse de ces appartements
du louvre et a besoin de plus de place
pour loger sa famille qui s'agrandit
bull en lui construire un nouveau palais
l'autel de la reine qu'on appellera plus
tard l'hôtel de soissons il n'en reste
aujourd'hui qu'une simple colonnes
doriques la colonne de l'horoscope qui
était alors dans la cour un escalier
mène à une plateforme surmonté d'une
cage de fer qui peut contenir trois
personnes un bal concerne le sommes la
fonction de cette colonne n'est pas
clair la pu être un poste d'observation
peut-être les astrologues de catherine
l'utilisent est il pour observer les
étoiles
catherine de médicis fait d'immenses
dépenses pour le palais de chenonceau
elle tente de surpasser les ouvrages de
son ancienne rivale
diane avait ajouté le joli pont en arc
qui enjambe le cher catherine construit
deux galeries dans l'extension dans les
jardins elle fait aménager des cascades
des ménageries des volières ainsi que
trois parcs catherine de médicis est une
bâtisseuse comme france à premier l'a
été et elle est dans la même logique
c'est à dire qu'elle construit beaucoup
elle a des tas de projets tout le temps
mais finit pas grand chose alors soit
parce que elle a d'autres idées soit
parce qu'ils manquent d'argent soit
parce que la cour a changé pour des
raisons politiques on a changé de lieu
ces constructions personnel n'en fin de
compte elle pourrait se résumer à trois
l'agrandissement de ce nom sow qui qui
n'est pas rien le palais des tuileries
qu'elle va se construire au milieu des
jardins du louvre et qui met ce qui ne
sera pas je fais non plus et puis
peut-être ce mausolée dont on oublie
souvent l'existence qu'elle avait voulu
construire à l'abbaye de saint denis
juste à côté de l'abbaye pour faire une
sorte de lieu à la gloire de son mari
d'elle et de ses enfants
[Musique]
en hommage à henri 2 elle décide
d'ajouter une nouvelle chapelle à la
basilique saint-denis appelait autrefois
rotonde des valois et elle commande un
magnifique tombeau pour henry est pour
elle le primate itx et célèbre artiste
qui avait travaillé à fontainebleau est
choisi pour mener à bien le projet il
conçoit la chapelle comme une tour
couronné par une coupole relié au
transept nord de la basilique
plusieurs des éléments construits pour
la chapelle des valois sont encore
debout
notamment le tombeau de catherine et
d'henri considéré par certains comme le
plus brillant des tombeaux royaux de la
renaissance les priant du roi et de la
reine sont agenouillés sur un dea de
marbre supporté par douze colonnes de
marbre leur gisant repose dans la crypte
en dessous le corps de catherine évoque
le sommeil plutôt que la mort tandis
qu'henri tient de manière saisissante sa
tête en arrière
catherine de médicis après la mort
d'henri 2 1 un grand projet évidemment
c'est de faire construire à saint denis
là où où tous les rois de france depuis
depuis l'origine était enterré à la
basilique de saint denis une
merveilleuse chapelle qui s'appellera la
chapelle des valois et puis elle va
aussi continuer de faire quelques
d'améliorer quelques châteaux elle
continue l'oeuvre architecturale
qu'avait souhaité son mari henri 2
catherine avait été fortement
impressionnés par l'exemple de françois
1er
elle reprend sa politique de grandeur sa
volonté de laisser derrière soi des
édifices prestigieux quel qu'en soit le
coût
elles dépensent des sommes astronomiques
à une époque où la monarchie est en
faillite et son autorité morale sur le
déclin alors que le pays sombre dans
l'anarchie
ces projets deviennent de plus en plus
ambitieux il reste peu de choses de
l'oeuvre de catherine de médicis
elle voulait se bâtir une image
glorieuse mais contrairement à son
illustre beau père elle ne laissera
aucun monument significatif en héritage
[Musique]
henry 2 parvint à relever les difficiles
défis de sa jeunesse il devint roi bon
fort honnête et loyal si sa vie n'avait
été si brève son règne aurait pu être un
moment positif de l'histoire de france
si l'on excepte le domaine religieux où
il se montra particulièrement
intolérants sa mort accidentelle fut une
catastrophe pour le royaume
la stabilité qu'il incarnait les sa
place à la lutte pour la régence avec
son cortège d intrigues de tromperie et
de troubles internes tel qu'on n'en
avait jamais vu auparavant à la cour de
france et qui conduisit aux guerres de
religion
rongé par la haine tant religieuse que
politique
la france va se déchirer durant quarante
ans la mort d'henri marque le crépuscule
des valois
ses fils monarque d'une grande faiblesse
feront tomber la monarchie au plus bas
catherine de médicis ne ramènera pas la
paix et occupera le trône d'une maison
qui a régné plus de 250 ans sur la
france le magnifique palais des
tuileries n'a pas survécu à la
révolution
si bien que les derniers rois de la
maison des valois n'ont marqué les
mémoires que par leur histoire tragique
et leurs faiblesses qui a précipité leur
faim